the jurogan experience like i remember
the first time i ever met anthony
bourdain
i said uh my wife says you're my
boyfriend
oh my god was he like
just like what the [ __ ] because i my
wife used to say oh you're watching your
boyfriend on tv should always joke
around because i love that no
reservation show yeah so i said that to
him it came out totally wrong
but that's a you know he's a guy i like
really admired and here he is he's right
there and you you're all uncomfortable
and weird and so people are going to be
like that with you i bet he was so down
to earth very super normal yeah he was
great so was de niro like i worked with
de niro the yeah did you deal with de
niro oh joe this is the best story i was
at the cellar late at night and he was
there with taylor hackford
looking he's a huge director married to
helen mirren he was the dir you know
head of the director's guild
um directed ray an officer and a
gentleman like a huge amount of movies
deniro was looking for comics to be in
his movie
and i was doing a set and i do this
thing in my act where i turn around and
talk to myself
my special's called talking to myself
where i have an inner dialogue
and i'm like it doesn't matter how this
goes you'll never make it you know like
i have a whole
back to the audience
and
and he loved it
and i i was i went to florida to do an
old age community [ __ ] jewish show oh
boy yeah and that saturday i get a call
and it's taylor hackford and he's like
this is taylor hackford and i'm like
okay i had no idea who the hell he was
he's like bob would like to meet with
you on wednesday and i'm like bob who
[Laughter]
i no idea i'm like bob the builder i had
no idea
he's like bob de niro and i'm like okay
so i'm like i can make it
so i walk into the the office and i walk
in the room and he's sitting there and i
was not starstruck it was the weirdest
thing because he looked like a just a
guy from off the street like he had
jeans on and i don't know i just he was
like a regular guy to me yeah
and i sat with him for three hours and i
hit it off with him and to make a very
long story short i ended up being his
right-hand person in this movie i beca i
got a producer credit i was in his ear
the whole time on a microphone i i
taught him how to do stand-up he played
a comic who had been doing it for 36
years in a movie called the comedian
i ended up directing some of the scenes
um
i mean it might have been like six years
ago something like that why do i not
know about this oh you got it yeah it's
it's yeah that's he and i yeah
we became very close wow i love him
comedian gives tips to robert de niro
yeah he's he's an amazing person
he really is that's cool so down to
earth you would think he has the biggest
ego he has no ego you can't be that good
he he doesn't i mean to be as good as he
is you got to have a pretty strong mind
yeah he's not and he
i think liked that i never
was starstruck with him like i didn't
care yeah i just sat with him and was
like
and we're still very close and i
i love him i really do like he just
he just doesn't give a [ __ ] he's so he's
so funny like he
he has all these kids he's like he's
just really amazing he's really amazing
he has six kids wow
yeah was one lady or a gang of chicks no
a couple
a couple different couple of different
baby moms yeah we like talking about
women together like he's [ __ ] amazing
yeah he just got divorced i know he's
the second timer that's the same woman
yeah same woman he got divorced yeah
when guys are that old and they get
divorced i'm like how bad must it be
yeah for the second time when you're
like you want to be alone and you're 78
or whatever well the guy let me tell you
something he's hot he works out every
morning at five in the morning with a
trainer yeah he's built he has tattoos
all over him i mean i used to sit in his
trailer yeah he's tatted up he's got
robert de niro has tattoos all over the
place i know his chest jamie find these
ones
there might be i mean there might be
photos but i would sit with him in his
trailer he was getting his makeup done
but
i hung out with harvey keitel they were
all in the movie harvey keitel danny
devito and i used to go out to dinner
with them and lunch with them every day
and i would be starting and harvey's
like you know harvey was like i want to
take you to lunch i want you to teach me
how to do stand-up so i went to lunch
with him i'm like i am not teaching
every old actor
but i said to harvey why did you you
know your jewish guy from new york why'd
you become a marine he goes so i could
kill people that's what he said to me
whoa yeah he's a tough dude he might not
want you to tell people that and he's
podcasting no he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] a mate to harvey keitel is
amazing
i love that he's a tough key
what an actor
one little [ __ ] ass tattoo yeah yeah
but he has more than that no he has one
more enemy he's 100 years old in this
movie no
no he has more than that on the other
arm he does he has more than that for
sure
like me no not like you this doesn't
have any tattoos
wow we must have got him after yeah wow
but that looks really recently
click on that robert deniro at the beach
no he doesn't have them like you
this three years ago you crazy lying
[ __ ] no you son
first of all why are you lying about
robert de niro
because they might have put more on him
for the movie i'm an idiot
but he does have them okay they're not
real no he has one in that photo yeah i
got one little bitch-ass tattoo look at
that stupid little tiger crawling up his
leg no but seriously it was after he had
makeup done maybe they put extra on him
i don't know i don't know if they did
um
how weird though did they appear in the
movie the tattoos
maybe got him remembered no he did have
more tattoos in the movie
yeah he did maybe he got him removed he
did because he was playing younger they
they uh painted his beard black you know
his
black he had a black mustache in black
so they probably he wasn't gray in the
movie he wanted to make him something
yeah he was like in his 60s in the movie
okay um
but he was great and he has no
he has no uh
like he's not stuck up or
like he's not egotistical he's not what
you people would think he is
well he's a real artist amazing i mean
if you want to do a film like taxi
driver or cape fear or any i mean any of
the transformative movies raging bull
i mean he was literally the first actor
to decide he was going to gain weight
for a movie right right
no one did that before him he
transformed his
literal body
i mean he was [ __ ] shredded and then
he became like really overweight for
that movie raging bull i know
i want to hear the best story the first
day of filming was at a deli in brooklyn
and taylor hackford didn't even know
that he like hired me to be his like
right-hand person so daenerys is just
good cause my music i want you to come
to brooklyn come to the to the filming
today i need you to punch up some jokes
for me
i'm like oh boy does taylor know i'm
coming he's like i don't care i just
want you to show up and help me out so
so i show up he's in the middle i get
there a little late because of traffic
he's in the middle of doing a scene with
uh with
danny devito and uh
patti lupone who plays danny devito's
wife
right
so i walk in de niro runs up to me goes
i need a joke for this line so i give
him a joke
so i go wait in the side and uh he says
the line and patty and danny start
hysterically laughing so taylor starts
yelling what the [ __ ] is going on here
we got to get through this why are they
laughing she goes well jessica came in
and gave me a joke so he comes over and
he starts yelling at me this is the
first day of filming because you can't
just do this you can't just come in here
and screw up everything and
de niro took his arm and he goes if you
ever [ __ ] talk to her like they start
screaming i'm like what is happening
where am i god i'm in the filming with
robert de niro i was just at the cellar
doing a set like what is happening he
goes don't you ever [ __ ] talk to her
like that again i mean that set the tone
for the next six months
because he knew not to talk to me and
like he set the tone like don't ever
talk to her
and i'm just sitting there like
eating a freaking like where am i
what's happening
it was amazing oh he i was treated like
gold after that
his temper is
yeah you don't
i mean when he yelled my hair blew
like my hair blew back
like a lion oh he was yeah he's a he's
you don't screw with him what was harvey
keitel like so intense
so what you would think he is like and
he would get enraged before a scene you
know like he was a real meisner actor
like
totally what you would think
very
charming attract i mean the three of
them together can you imagine going to
dinner with danny devito harvey keitel
and
and de niro i mean it was like unreal
that's incredible and leslie mann was in
it so judd was around a lot i mean it
was fun wow it was fun watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify